[موسيقى]
لم تلقى دوره لكاس العالم بكره القدم ما
لقيته الدوره الثانيه والعشرون في قطر من
الكيد والهجوم المتعدد الجهات والاتجاهات
فاستحضر الاحياء والاموات في معركه مع
الفطره لدرجه التقدم معها الناشطين
النباتيين اين هم لا يرشقون مطاعم اللحوم
في الدوحه بالتلاوين في المقابل لم تتبنى
شعوب العربيه حدثا منذ مده طويله كما تبنت
مونديال قطر ليس لاجل الرياضه فقط بل لان
الاستحقاق ضبطه المنظم على ايقاع يماثل
البيت المسلم والعربي الذي يفتح مصراعيه
لكل الضيوف وبكل الحب لكن الاحذيه تخلع
عند الابواب فلل البيت طهره وطهارته
احببت شعوبنا مونديال قطر لانه يشبهها
ويشبه من يشبهها فتحول شعبي الى مونديال
فلسطين ونشيده العفوي المغني كان انا دمي
فلسطيني ردده العربي والاعجمي من المشرق
والمغارب الى البرازيل والصين فبدا بضعه
من الصحفيين الاسرائيليين في شوارع الدوحه
مربكين برحله انتهت قبل ان تبدا لا احدا
هنا يريد ان يتحدث اليهم فالدم الفلسطيني
واللبناني والسوري اثقل من حبر طواقيع
اتفاقيات نسبت هي الاخرى زورا الى ابي
الانبياء ابراهيم عليه السلام
وهكذا تكون فلسطين
واسرائيل الدولتان الغائبتان عن كره
الملاعب اللاعبين الاكثر حضورا في مونديال
قطر احدهما في موقع الخاسر الاكبر والاخر
في مقعد الربح الاكيد الى العناوين
الاعلام الاسرائيلي يسال هل الانظمه
المطبعه في واد وشعوبها في وادي اخر
صحفي اسرائيلي يتحول في الدوحه وزميله
المقاتل يتقمص دور صحفي
جينات الكرم العربي تفيض ومشجعون اجانب
لمواطنهم لا تصدقوا اعلامنا
فرحه عربيه كبرى بمنتخب المغرب تصل الى
مخيمات النزوح السوريه
قطر مروج خضراء غناء سقطه اعلاميه للبي بي
سي ام خطا فني
محلل الماني يقترح ممارسات شاذه في ملاعب
المباريات انتصارا للمثليين
فاس ملطخه بالدماء هديه فاجنر للاتحاد
الاوروبي بعد وصمه روسيا بالارهاب
وزير الداخليه الهندي يفاخر بمجازر عباده
ارتكبت بحق المسلمين
ويهدد بتكرارها
بعيدا عن السياسه هل يكره المسلمون السنه
والشيعه بعضهم بعضا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
استطاع الذئب والتخفي عن ليله في الحكايه
الشهيره لكن ليل الان كبرت وصارت تتعرف
على الوحوش بسهوله مهما حاولت التخفي
والتحلي بعناوين خادعه
الشعوب العربيه لا تحبون رغم اتفاقيات
التطبيع يقول مراسل اسرائيلي من قطر فيما
قناه اسرائيل 24 تسال هل كان رفض التطبيعه
الذي عبر عنه المشجعون العرب في الدوحه
متوقعا هل الانظمه المطبعه في واد وشعوبها
في واد اخر فهل بامكانكم اصدقاءنا
المشاهدين ان تدونوا اجوبتكم بدايه على
هذين السؤالين البديهيين في الشيت بخلطه
جيش باريس سان جيرمان
[موسيقى]
معكم
في قطر من قليل الخبر الى الخبر بحديثاته
هل اثبت ما يجري ان اتفاقيات ابراهيم
التطبيعيه في واد والشعوب العربيه من
بينها شعوب الدول المطبعه في وادي اخر
الاعلام الاسرائيلي التفرغ للحديث عن
الاكتشاف المتاخر لحجم كره العرب لاسرائيل
مع ان سرطانا من نوع اخر هو سرطان الثدي
اوجد له اختبار الاكتشاف المبكر
صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت تصف مونديال الحب
فلسطين بمونديال الكراهيه والخارجيه
الاسرائيليه تحتج على قطر والفيفا وتنصح
الاسرائيليين بعدم السفر الى الدوحه وقد
تقرر الاسرائيليين لعدم السفر الى قطر
لانها خطر عليهم بالاضافه الى سؤال لماذا
يكرهنا العرب صار على الاسرائيليين ان
يسالوا لماذا يكره من اليابانيون
ازرول
اغنيه الشهيره انا دمي فلسطيني لم يبقى
جمهور عربي الا وغنداها في الدوحه لكنها
تكون اقوى واقعا باصوات المشجعين
البرازيليين
[موسيقى]
ان ياتي مشجع اسرائيلي الى الدوحه لتشجيع
المانيا مثلا او البرازيل او غيرهما ضمن
شروط الفيفا على البلد المضيف امر مختلف
عليه لكن ما يحظى بالاجماع هو منعو رفع
العلم الاسرائيلي على المدرجات الشرطه
القطريه تنتزعت علم الاحتلال الذي حمله
المشجع راعي بن شلوسه انتزعته من سلوشه
عموله
مع العرب
اكمنوه اكوامان
اسرائيل
صحفي جندي اسرائيلي يتخفى في مونديال قطر
بصفه امبور صانع سلام وكتيبتهم متخصصه
بقتل الاطفال والنساء يقولوا التقرير
مال
اي سؤال
[موسيقى]
كله الاطفال تقريبا يحبون الشوكولا وكل
الاطفال يكرهون اسرائيل حتى لو كانت مغمسه
بالشوكولا طفل قطري ينجح ويتالق في مصيده
كاميرا خفيه
[موسيقى]
قاعدين يوزعون البيوت اللي عند الملعب
يوزعوا لنا اكل وفطاير ومشروبات بيض الله
وجيهكم يا شباب ما قصرتوا رحم الله
والديكم جينات والكرم العربي فاضت في
منطقه الثمامه بالدوحه حيث يعد اهلها طعام
العشاء للمراه من المشجعين فلا تصدق ما
يقال في بلادنا عن بلادهم امريكي يودعوا
قطر بحرقه
[موسيقى]
مع الفوز الثمين لمنتخبه فكان العرب جميعا
ليلتها مغاربه حتى النازحون في الشمال
السوري وزعوا البقلاوه في صالات عرض
مباريات المونديال احتفالا بفوز اسود
الاطلس فطريجا متزوج من مغربيه يغني
للمغرب ومغربي يرد التحيه باحسن منها هدف
فقط ونفتخر النجوم ديالي من منطقه غريب
الحمد الفوز والمنتخب المغربي
يحي المغرب رايت ما لا اراه من جماله ومن
استقبال ومن تواضع الله يحفظ تميم واولاد
تميم والشعب قطر الاعزاء انا لا اقول هذا
لاي ارمي الورد لاول مره في حياتي
رحتوا جميع الدول الاوروبيه وامريكا ولم
ارى جماليه وتواضع هذا الشعب الف مبروك
الف مبروك
من حديث لرسول الله محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام لا تقوم الساعه حتى تعود ارض
العرب مروجا وانهارا رواه مسلم لكن جزيره
العرب لم تعد مروجا خضراء بعد الا على بي
بي سي التي نشرت صوره لمرج اخضر مع مشجعين
للعبه كره القدم تحت عنوان خبر يدعي وجود
مشجعين مزيفين في مونديال قطر فتبين ان
الصوره عائده الى منطقه كيرلا في الهند
فهل كانت بي بي سي تقصد ان هذه الطبيعه
الخضراء قطريه ام انها صوره في غير محلها
لخبر ليس اقله اهتزازا من موقف قطاع النقل
في لندن الذي يقاطع كاس العالم فيمنع
اعلاناته بشكل كامل احتجاجا على القوانين
القطريه التي تحضر المثليه في العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن اختفت الاعلانات عن كاس
العالم والدوله المضيفه قطر ردا على
قوانين الدوله الخليجيه المتصله بمجتمع
الميم وملف المثليه الجنسيه
قال الامين العام الاسبق لجامعه الدول
العربيه على مر موسى ان قطر احسن ناس
استغلال مواردها وعملت بذكاء كبير مكنها
من الظهور كلاعب مؤثر على الساحه الدوليه
فهل ستحسن الدوحه فعلا استثمار مواردها
الان في لجم الهجمه الغربيه عليها
صحيفه فايننشيل تايمز تقول ان قطر ستراجع
استثماراتها في لندن
فان قطر قررت اعاده النظر في كامل
استثمارتها في مدينه لندن وهي استثمارات
ضخمه ومتشعبه
سلام عليكم سلام عليكم
سلام عليكم سلام عليكم سلام عليكم
وعليكم السلام
ستاتي الينا ستحترم ديننا ثقافتنا اعرافنا
وقوانيننا غير ذلك ضع يدك حيثما تشاء هكذا
علق الصحفي القطري محمد الكعبي على وضع
اعضاء المنتخب الالماني كفوفهم على
افواههم تعبيرا عن استنكار منع قطر
الترويج للمثليه الجنسيه فيما دعا النجم
العربي محمد ابو تريكه اللاعبين الالمان
الى احترام انفسهم احنا قوم اعزنا الله
بالاسلام وابنه مش هنغير تحط لي ايدك ما
تحطليش ايدك احترم نفسك انت وهو واحترم
قوانين البلد قطر نقلتنا من حته دائما كنا
مستضعفين فيها بيقول ابن خلدون المغلوب
مولع بتقليد الغالب احنا كنا فتره من
الفترات بنقلوا دلوقت لا قصه خمسه
ياما ياما فتره تولع
عيونك ضحك
القرن بل القرون تطوع به محلل الماني
للاحتيال على القوانين القطريه فدعى الى
ممارسات شاذه على ارض الملعب امام
الجماهير بعد تسجيل كل هدف
عيد سعيد
المونديال وتمثل الحملات الصليبيه حيث
يمكن ان تكون موسيقى للمسلمين بحسب الفيفا
وذلك بسبب مجازر الاباده التي ارتكبتها
الحملات الصليبيه بحق المسلمين
والامر يشبه ان ترفع شعار النازيين في
ملاعب اوروبا براي نجم نادي ليفربول
السابق جون بانزويراز
[موسيقى]
بعد تصنيف الاتحاد الاوروبي روسيا دوله
راعيه للارهاب مجموعه بدر الروسيه ترسل
فاسا ملطخه بالدماء الى البرلماني
الاوروبي على غرار افلام المافيا
والجاسوسيه اقدمت مجموعه الروسيه على تصرف
تصعيدي في رساله تهديديه لاوروبا اذا
ارسلت المجموعه مطرقه ملطخه بالدماء الى
البرلمان الاوروبي
جرائم اكثر بشاعه ارتكبتها في سوريا فهل
الدم السوري دون مستوى الدم الاوكراني وفق
تصنيفهم في تشرين الثاني نوفمبر 2019
صورا يظهر عناصر من مرتزقه فاجنر اثناء
تعذيبهم لشاب سوري في محافظه دير الزور
باستخدام مطرقه ثم عمده الى قطع يديه
وراسه ولاحقا اح جثه الاف النساء الفرنسيه
تتعرضن اما للتحرش واما للاغتصاب واما
للعنف الاسري واما الاثنتين او الثلاثه
معا من هذه الموبقات التي تتقاعس الشرطه
الفرنسيه عن وضع حد لها كل التضامن مع
النساء الفرنسيات الضحايا لن نضع اكفنا
على افواهنا بل سنضعها على قلوبنا تضامنا
مع المراه الفرنسيه تحرش اغتصاب عنف اسريه
سنويا
24 ليله عوده تتعرض مجددا لاعتداءات
مستوطنين اسرائيليين لا يريدون ان يسمعوا
كلاما عربيا في المكان كله التضامن ايضا
مع ليلى ومع قافله الاعلاميين ضحايا القمع
والتنكيل
على عروضي بحري اسرائيل
في افغانستان مجاعه صامته الغرب ليس راضيا
عن حكومه طالبان وقد اختار ان يضع يده على
اموال لكابل يحتجزها في بنوكه بدل تقديم
يد العون لفقراء الافغان الذين بات بعضهم
يخدروا اطفاله الجياع مع عجزهم عن اطعامهم
كلهم
الجياع بدل اطعامهم بسبب الفقر الشديد
كلفت حبه المخدر اقل من رغيف خبز من يفكر
بالاعتداء على الاطفال غير المجرمين
والمعتوهين في ان واحد
وماذا عن الاعتداء على قبور الاطفال يحدث
هذا في المانيا
المعتدون كالعاده مجهولون نسبوا في
الاعلام الى حركات طائفيه
للمسلمين اما مسرحه تخريبهم فكان
اطفال مسلمين في شمال البلاد
كل التضامن
الصليب المعقول شعار النازيه الاجراميه
التاريخيه حمله شاب او فتن برازيلي في
السادسه عشر من عمره اثناء ارتكابه مجزره
فرديه بالسلاح في مدرستين قتل خلالها
ثلاثه اشخاص وجرح اكثر من 10 قبل ان
يستسلم للشرطه ايضا وايضا كل التضامن
مع ارتفاع وتيره القصف الروسي لمدينه
خيرسون الاوكرانيه وسقوط ضحايا وانقطاع
الكهرباء والانترنت اتهامات لروسيا
بارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه بحق المدنيين
مع هؤلاء المدنيين
نتضاما انصح الاتهام
روسيا الاخير يعني هناك ازمه حقيقيه وهناك
انقطاع في شبكات الاتصال والانترنت هناك
ظلام جامد يا عم اوكرانيا يبدو ان روسيا
بعد تحقيق مطالبها ترجع ترجع الى جرائم ضد
الانسانيه اما الان فقط حان وقت التضامن
مع كوكب الارض بعد اعلان الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي كيم جونغ اون عن هدفه الراهن
بامتلاكي اقوى سلاح استراتيجي في العالم
اقوى سلاح استراتيجي في العالم فقال انه
يظهر تصميم كوريا الشماليه وقدرتها على
بناء اقوى جيش في العالم
التطرف والعنف ضد المسلمين في الهند فانهم
لا يتحدثون عن حالات عابره من رجال الدين
وناشطين ارهابيين هنوس بل عن رجالات
الدوله الراهنه من حزب بهاراتها جنات
الحاكم وزير الداخليه الهندي اوميت شاه له
من اسمه اذا عرف نصيب اميت للموت عنوان
يتفاخر بعباده 2000 مواطن من المسلمين في
ولايه غزرت عام 2002 بعد تركيب تهمم
مختلفه لهم بالقيام باعمال شغب وهذا وزير
الداخليه اي وزير الامن الداخلي فهل
يتضامن الغرب اللطيف مع ضحايا الاباده في
كجره
المسلمون السنه والشيعه بيكرهوا بعض اما
مفكرين حالهم بيكرهوا بعض سؤال طرحه شاب
من ضحيه بيروت الجنوبيه بعدما تحدث عن
فرحه شعبيه في الضاحيه بعيدا عن السياسه
بفوز السعوديه في مباراتها الشهيره مع
الارجنتين
السعوديه يعني وين انا قاعد بالضاحيه يعني
ضاحيه يعني شيعه يعني حزب الله يعني
معروف بيناتنا قديش هيكفي
هنقول كده عدم وفاء كل واحد يسميه مثل ما
بده والله العظيم يا اخي شو بعرف انه نحن
بنكره بعض ولا مفكرين حالنا بنكره بعض ولا
شو بالظبط ما حدا فاهماني يا اخي هل اطلقت
بلاعب قطر جوله وديه جديده بين الحكوميتين
المصريه والتركيه
مع الرئيس السيسي لمده 45 دقيقه واتفقنا
على ان يجتمع وزراءنا ليتم توسيع وتطوير
اللقاءات الى اجتماعات الاخرى ياتي هذا
القرار بعد انصافح اردوغان السيسي على
هامشي فعاليات افتتاح نهائيات كاس العالم
في قطر مصافحه مفاجئه اتت بواسطه قطريه
في المتفرقات يقولوا الكاتب الفرنسي ساشا
جيت 3 نادرا ما يكون الزواج الزواج عقل
لكن الطلاق يجب ان يكون طلاق عقل لان
الزوجين باتي يعرف كل منهما الاخر في
خبريتنا التاليه لا نبحث عن العقل في
الطلاق بل في اعلان الطلاق بحد ذاته رجل
من دمياط لم يجد افضل من عرس ابنته موعدا
ومسرحا لاعلاني طلاقي زوجته منه وبالثلاثه
الف الف مبروك للعريس والعروسه الا
بالنسبه لام العروسه فهي الثلاثه وتروح من
قال
الف مبروك اخيرا في البحرين تمت بنجاح
عمليه اداء قسم اليمين لعضو مجلس امانه
العاصمه بشار احمدي
والاحترام الدستور وقوانين الدوله وان
اودي اعمالي بالامانه والصدق
[موسيقى]
ختاما اكرم وشادي البوريني مغنيان شعبيان
فلسطينيان معروفات اكرم كان يشجع منتخب
حياته لكنه الانقلب عليه بدفع من شادي فهو
لطالما شجع اللاعبين الالمان على ان يضعوا
الاهداف بارجلهم في المرمى وليس على ان
يضع اكفهم في الملعب اليوم على افواههم
وغدا لا احد يدري اين سيضعونه الى اللقاء
حب الالماني اكرم نعرف له بميداني هاي
العادي الخوالي اوعك لا بيحبوا الالوان
بحب المرسيدس بنزلها فيها العالم كنز بوش
الالماني اللي يجز ويستفز بنين
وهمه شو بنعرف همه
على يرجعوا على المكان بابا بحب المنتخب
[موسيقى]